[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
opening statements are presented as r b
singer r kelly faces federal sex crimes
charges and what caused a string of
delays in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial we're here for a
status on the
dauber hearing that was scheduled for
monday
which i understand is no longer
necessary plus the sandy hook civil
lawsuit in connecticut moves forward
amid accusations that alex jones
attorneys committed ethical violations
but first opening statements are
presented as an ohio man stands trial
for the murder of his wife they were
walking down the bike path
walking in a westward direction and
eventually they found the remains of
them
trauma is is almost an understatement as
to what emily
had lived through hear from both sides
in the case of matthew moore long crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber opening statements are
presented in the staged suicide trial of
matthew moore as he faces murder trial
charges in the 2020 ohio death of his
wife emily noble noble was reported
missing on may 24 2020 after celebrating
her 52nd birthday with her husband
hundreds of volunteers conducted search
parties but more reportedly never took
part in september noble's decomposing
body was found in a wooded area in
westerville ohio not far from the
couple's home with a usb cord wrapped
around her neck authorities say her
death was staged to look like a suicide
but evidence pointed to a homicide
dental records had to be used to
identify the body and an autopsy
revealed noble suffered multiple facial
and neck fractures moore was arrested
seven months later and charged with
murder and felonious assault though
detectives have not announced what led
them to suspect moore in their opening
statements tuesday afternoon prosecutors
told the jury that moore waited hours
before calling a friend about noble
being missing and that his statements
after her death were inconsistent
prosecutors also told jurors of when the
victim's body was found in the woods
you hear testimony from the three
individuals they found emily that
they were walking down the bike path
walking in a westward direction and
eventually they found out the remains of
them found what they were looking for
you'll hear
that they called westerville police
and at that time
emily was finally found
you'll see pictures
of the scene taken
from bci
you'll see pictures
of emily and how she's situated
and
what you'll see is that she was in a
kneeling position
under a
tree that was about six
almost six and a half feet
tall and was found with a micro usb cord
wrapped around her neck
moore's defense attorney told the jury
that prosecutors have a lack of evidence
in this case and that noble's mental
health history proves more is innocent
the state in its opening talked about
emily's traumatic life emily's first
husband killed himself
by shooting his head in 2011.
a year later in 2012 the evidence will
show one of her very good friends
killed herself
the evidence will show that
in 2017
her brother-in-law by marriage so mark's
brother kills himself
in 2019
joey hangs himself in a park from a tree
trauma is is almost an understatement as
to what emily
had lived through but joey
her stepson
and again our openings aren't arguments
but the state said emily was passionate
about joke
and the evidence will certainly support
her passion and love for joey and what
that loss
in 2019 did to her
emotionally and physically
the first witness called to the stand
after opening statements was noble's
sister amy thomas on direct examination
she testified about moore alluding to
not wanting to find his wife under a
tree just a day after she went missing
turn your attention to
may 26th
did you
notice this way had you received
communications from people who were
interested in going out to look for
emily yes
and did you
communicate that
to
matt in that same facebook chat that had
you mad and emily yes
um
and what was his response
to you talking about a search party this
i remember he
um
he said he didn't want to go out and
look to find her dead under a tree
somewhere
that that's isn't that what search
parties are for
and he said he wanted to just let the
police search for her
all right let's talk about this joining
us today is former senior homicide
prosecutor and trial attorney bernardo
villalona and former prosecutor melba
pearson it's great to have you both here
in melbourne start with you let's start
with the openings right what what stood
out to you the most who do you think
gave the better presentation overall
well i would say that the prosecution
gave a much more
um
scientific
like bullet pointed kind of presentation
there wasn't a lot of passion there
wasn't a lot of emotion and again based
on
the evidence there may be enough of that
in the prosecutor's case that the
prosecutor decided to do a more
understated opening but i would say that
the defense's opening is much more
passionate much more trying to connect
with the jury right out the gate and
talking about the pain that the
the victim endured throughout her life
including the loss of her son and how
that may play into their defense so i
think they went about it in different
ways the prosecutor was much more
understated the defense was much more
passionate and trying to connect so
moving away from the opening statements
let's move on to the witness testimony
moore didn't want to search for his wife
and find her dead under a tree and it
kind of looks like a red flag until we
learn that his son was found dead in the
woods the year before that so bernarda
what do you make of that is it not such
a bad statement
so it's not such a bad statement well we
got to think of what we think is normal
is definitely probably not normal to
mister to this defendant in terms of
what's going on here it's sad that the
sister had to come in and testify she's
testifying about the last moments that
she had with her sister and now as she
thinks about things things just weren't
normal what was said by her supposed
husband and all of those are coming up
as red flags and those red flags may do
women at the end but there's still i
think a lot to go on we just got to wait
and see we do and it's an interesting
start to what is a really unique trial
in a unique case still ahead on long
crime daily alex jones attorneys appear
in court for yet another disciplinary
hearing but first a jury is seated and
opening statements are presented in the
second federal trial of disgraced singer
r kelly
[Music]
welcome back everybody a jury is seated
and opening statements are presented as
r kelly's federal trial in illinois
begins the one celebrated r b singer
faces 13 federal charges in illinois
including receiving child pornography
enticing minors into illegal sexual
activity and obstruction of justice back
in 2008 kelly was acquitted by an
illinois jury for creating a video of
himself having sex with a 14 year old
girl now at the time the girl and her
parents denied involvement and the
alleged victim refused to testify
federal prosecutors say that witnesses
and their families were threatened and
paid off in that case but this time
around prosecutors say the alleged
victim and several other women
victimized by kelly will take the stand
kelly maintains his innocence and
pleaded not guilty to the charges in
wednesday's opening statements
prosecutors told jurors that kelly went
to great lengths to cover up his sexual
relationships with multiple minors the
defense countered saying kelly has been
portrayed as a monster by the quote
criminals that are his accusers last
year
kelly was convicted on separate federal
charges of racketeering and sex crimes
in june he was sentenced to 30 years in
prison
malba the ongoing saga here i mean this
comes less than two months ago when
kelly received a 30-year federal
sentence for similar crimes can we
expect another conviction here or maybe
he'll get acquitted
listen anything is possible jesse we
know that trials are unpredictable the
folks that you think you have solid that
are going to come in and testify may get
cold feet at the last minute they may
get threatened again any of those things
are possible but i find it highly
unlikely that this case would result in
anything less than a conviction because
of the fact that the federal prosecutors
had time to prepare they had time to
shore up their witnesses to make sure
that they will participate so i think
it's highly likely that the feds are
going to notch another conviction on
their belts with regards to this case
bernardo this is an interesting point
and that's that kelly's defense team
they pushed for a jury to not see the
docuseries surviving r kelly but a judge
denied that request so it makes me
wonder
are these jurors well aware of kelly's
past
that's going to be a problem jesse i
think it's going to be a problem in
terms of for the prosecution that r
kelly if he does get convicted in this
federal case coming out of illinois that
he probably has some strong appealable
grounds especially since you're talking
about people on that jury we don't know
if this is sure for sure that people on
that jury have already seen the
docu-series and the reason why is
because they're expecting that at least
one or two people that were in those
docu-series are going to testify at this
trial so that means that they've been
pre-disposed to the allegations in this
case and it makes it hard for them to be
a fair and impartial juror if that is
the case and talk about the jury in
videos it's my understanding they're
actually going to
see these videos of these alleged sex
acts which is you know really something
in this case so it'll be hard for the
defense to refute that switching now
over to california where a los angeles
county sheriff's department chief
apologizes to kobe bryant's widow after
photos of his deadly helicopter crash
were shared this comes as part of
vanessa bryant's civil lawsuit against
los angeles county bryant argues that
first responders inappropriately shared
photos of the crash to people outside
the fire and police departments in
january 2020 the nba star his daughter
gianna and seven others were killed when
the helicopter they were flying in
tragically crashed chief jorge valdez
took the stand on tuesday where he
apologized to vanessa bryan as well as
co-plaintiff christopher chester after
learning that no apology had ever been
made before this apology echoes opening
statements from brian's lawyer who told
jurors to make note of first responders
who apologize while testifying saying
that previous apologies had never been
made
and also in california jurors hear from
a canine cadaver dog handler in the
death of kristin's smart trial 19 year
old smart went missing back in 1996 when
she was a student at california
polytechnic state university though her
body was never found she was legally
declared dead in 2002. father and son
reuben and paul flores now stand trial
in connection to smart's murder paul
flores was the last person seen with
smart before her disappearance and faces
charges of murder ruben flores is
charged with accessory after allegedly
helping hide the body after the fact on
monday a canine handler who searched
cali poly in 1996 took the stand and she
told jurors that two separate police
dogs gravitated toward paul flores dorm
both dogs pointed out the side of the
room that has lived on and motioned
towards his bed multiple times now this
trial is not being recorded or live
streamed due to orders by a california
judge
coming up on long prime daily after
multiple delays and a trial hiatus the
parkland school shooter is back in court
plus yet another defamation case on the
dock for alex jones why wednesday's
disciplinary hearing may not be the last
[Music]
welcome back everybody the connecticut
civil case against conspiracy theorist
alex jones will move forward with jury
selection beginning thursday as he faces
lawsuits from several victims families
in the sandy hook massacre the decision
comes days after a texas jury decided
the infowars host should pay nearly 50
million dollars in defamation damages to
the parents of a six-year-old who was
killed in the 2012 elementary school
shooting this all stems from jones's
comments made to his audience after the
massacre when he said that the shooting
of 20 first graders and six educators
was a hoax staged by government actors
in order to push gun control
jury selection will begin thursday for
the lawsuit filed by eight other
families as well as an fbi agent who
responded to the shooting the decision
to move forward with the case came after
a judge stripped jones of the protection
that he was seeking when he put the
parent company of infowars into
bankruptcy the topic of a hearing on
wednesday was jones attorneys as two of
them are facing disciplinary hearings
for how they handled confidential files
including medical and psychiatric
records of plaintiffs in the case the
judge asked for dates and specifics
about the sharing of the files but the
zoom hearing ended before any decisions
were made of whether ethics rules were
violated
any recording is to order to be stopped
at this point we are going to go off the
record um i will not be staying on and
we will now book we're going to just
book two days
before the start of evidence in the um
in these lawsuits too and it may be that
we just need one day but we'll book the
second day just in case all right
thank you council we're adjourned
all right a little anticlimactic there
but melbourne we've already seen
multiple disciplinary hearings for jones
attorney shouldn't this be a red flag
for their client and maybe also
shouldn't the attorneys know full well
how to deal with confidential documents
at this stage in their careers they
absolutely should know how to handle
confidential documents but again it may
speak to the type of case that this is
right i mean if you're looking for
counsel to represent you in a very
sensitive matter obviously we know that
everyone has the right to a defense etc
etc but at the same token do you really
want to put your name on the line for
this type of defendant for these types
of charges you may be seen as co-signing
some of the horrible things that he said
about these families so i think that
speaks to the types of attorneys that
might be willing to take on this case as
opposed to others so i think that may be
what's going to play here bernard it
feels like deja vu doesn't i mean didn't
we just cover an alex jones defamation
trial in texas do you think that this
connecticut trial is going to be any
different
i'm hoping that the judge will have more
order in her courtroom in the
connecticut trial in the sense of not
letting alex jones do what he wants to
do because remember he also didn't
appear for several of i think not even
for the damages section to find out how
much he's going to have to pay he wasn't
even in there for punitive damages so
let's see if he even shows up for the
trial for the entire trial but we're
dealing with the same subject matter
we're dealing with all of his lies and
lies and lies about what actually took
place and how he hurt these families
that have been grieving since they lost
their loved ones
well i'll tell you what i'll be looking
out for if he decides to go on infowars
during the course of the trial and
comment on the trial like he did last
time where he made fun of the jury and
the judge and the plaintiffs we'll all
be on the lookout for that one
when we come back the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial defense
attorneys explain why this week's dalver
hearing was canceled and the evidence
will no longer be presented
welcome back the parkland school shooter
is back in court following a series of
delayed and canceled hearings last
october the shooter pleaded guilty to 17
counts of murder and 17 counts of
attempted murder and it's now up to a
broward county jury to determine whether
he receives life in prison or the death
penalty after a recess in court last
week a dalbert hearing was scheduled to
be presented on monday the hearing was
unexpectedly canceled when the defense
said it would no longer present on
issues that were brought up by
prosecutors now the dalbert hearing was
meant to discuss a series of the
defendant's brain scans that may have
shown brain damage at a status hearing
on wednesday both sides explained why
the evidence wouldn't need to be
presented
we're not relying on those uh
the specific things outlined in the
state's daughter
here
so that's why that's why the hearings
don't want to necessarily because we're
not relying on those types of scans or
comparisons
that the state was objected to that's
correct yes
state are you in agreement with
with that
uh judge yes and just for the record
it's the neuroquant the confusion tensor
imaging which is dti uh quantitative eeg
and the mid neuro that was the basis of
the state's motion to exclude
under gaubert uh he received an email
sunday night from the department that
they no longer tend to rely on any of
that evidence in
their mitigation presentation
so uh
obviously there's no need to go for the
hearing we would ask however that the
court colloquy the defendant on this
issue
now the judge ruled that when both sides
present an agreed order she will sign it
and then colloquy the defendant melba
the defense won't use the brain scans
that the prosecution opposed but the
defendant still needs to reply to a
colloquy so does that mean that he will
that we're going to hear from him in
court what do you think that might look
like break it down for us
yeah so basically
the judge asked the defendant a series
of questions to make sure that he
understands that those scans are not
going to be used that he agrees with the
strategy that his defense counsel is
using and that he is fully aware and is
willingly
entering into this next phase of the
trial so again he's agreeing and
understands what's happening so that way
on appeal there's not that issue of well
i didn't agree with what my defense my
defense counsel was proposing i really
did want those scans to be entered into
evidence as mitigation so that's to make
sure that that issue then gets resolved
and he is saying on the record that he
understands what's going on and he
agrees with the path that's been chosen
and it's important because there has
been a question if he's understands
what's going on during the course of
this and so bernarda we know that court
proceedings are expected to resume as
normal next week with the defense
beginning its case what are you
expecting to see now from the defense
well the first thing i'm going to expect
to see is an opening statement because
remember after the prosecution did their
opening statement when they started the
trial the defense decided not to do an
opening statement at that time they
reserved their opening statement for a
later time so monday will be the time
for them to deliver their opening
statements so i'm curious what
mitigating factors that they're going to
focus on to deem that that nicholas cruz
should be worthy of living and serving
out his time inside of a prison as
opposed to the death penalty also i
assume that of course they're going to
seek out sympathy sympathy sympathy
sympathy that's going to be their number
one focus in order to try to convince at
least one juror to hold out when it
comes to this sentence and i've said it
before and i'll say it again you know
they don't even have to present that
much where the jury can come back and
say we've seen so much death and
destruction in this case we just don't
even feel necessary that one other
person should die and that might be it
bernarda melba thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you